ideas provocadoras la neutralidad muchas
veces es una excusa que usamos los
periodistas para escondernos de nuestra
verdadera responsabilidad nuevas maneras
de pensar si queréis decirle a alguien
que le queréis para siempre
te voy a regalar diamante pero si le
queréis decir que le queréis a siempre
siempre regalarlo teorema historias
increíbles en un segundo vi a mis pies
al comandante guerrillero amordazado y
el jefe del rescate gritando somos el
ejército de colombia están libres
bienvenidos al podcast de ted en español
cada semana les traemos charlas de los
principales líderes y creadores de
diversas partes del mundo en directo
desde eventos ted y tdx en el fondo
somos ningún lado del todo y de todos
lados un poco muchas gracias
suscríbete hoy al nuevo podcast de ted y
univisión
ted en español ideas en nuestro idioma
[Música]